How's it going everyone welcome to cringe Thursday
(EpIC ThEME)
Cringe what day is it Oh
Thursday this week's tea comes from Trisha Paytas. I'm about five weeks late on this
It was one of those things where you see in your peripheral you like. I don't really care about that
But then the more you look into it, you're like Jesus Christ that's a full blown panda!
And that's about it with Trisha Paytas. And sadly I couldn't be a Teletubby, but you know what? I became one
I am one.
I'm a mother[frick]ing Teletubby
I AM A MOTHERF*CKI-
He/she might be a lot of things
Teletubby is not one of them.
Liar manipulator
playing victim
aggressive abusive not a Teletubby
So what has she done recently?
Well a couple things two things I knew about Trisha from this god forbidden video called showering with my boyfriend
Whatever you do do not watch this video. It's a cursed video. [I don't know buddy]
Just don't watch this video me with my sleep paralysis demon
To whoever was the cameraman we send a deep prayer to you
Trisha has been wheezing her way in in different ways where I hope that I would never see her again after that video
She's been part of the david dobrik vlogs. She's been doing her regulars Spiel of crying
Almost as good as me crying in my car
But recently she got there in a bit the drama with Nikocado Avocado
Do you want to lose some brain cells? Great keep watching you see Trisha Paytas had the competition
For who would make a cover of her song and Nikocado Avocado made a beautiful song
It's actually not bad I didn't know you had any other talent but crying about who God knows what while eating
Did you send a hotel room?
What the f*ck is this!?
When you give up on your talent and dreams
Mukbang. Yeah, Trisha saw this cover that
Nicodo Avocado did of her video and she be like I have loved you for so long as a fan and this blew
My mind when I saw it in the subscription, so she was subscribed even we need to get together in person
There is something about you and then this I'm speechless
Truly, I can't think of the right words to say and then she tweets him going like hey, babe
Where do you live we need to collab. Love ASAP. Your uh never brought tears. DM
What relevance does this have to anything Felix? Well, I'll have you know that Trisha
Invited him to collab he flew all the way from Colombia and she just ghosted him. Uh-huh
Okay, so Trisha Paytas right now. I've been watching you for a few months. I just adore you
I don't know if you've seen my videos about not one to be vegan anymore
But it would be so fun to eat something non vegan with you
She respond. Hell yeah
Actually, I'm pretty free next week. What day are you thinking? I said, I'm free on next week - I just do YouTube
That's a super flexible so you can pick the day. I'm looking at flights now
So I let her know I'm flying I said I'm looking at the flights
I'll let her know are you available but she says I'm free all week
I said I've never been to California before the best flight deal is Tuesday the 17th then
She responds I can make that work. I can make that work. Hi, Trisha
I came to LA to see ya but I don't know how to get a whole. Yeah, is everything okay?
Next one says if I did something wrong he let me know I have gifts from you from Colombia
He brought gifts from Colombia. This is opposed to be cringe. We're getting into the cringe
The cringe is bad area if it has meaning behind it, okay?
But the best part about this, is that even though Trisha clearly
Publicly said that she subscribed to him watch his videos and wanted to collab with him on mine. There's a different story
I was never going to I wasn't gonna like collab. You heard a meanie. I don't know where that came from your text message
Where that come from and I was like they were all like Trisha goes to him
I was like Trisha didn't even know that he was coming no idea no idea
No, I dad don't like all that
The only thing I heard of him wasn't he did my warrior cover you said you were subscribed in the comments of that video?
The only thing I heard of him was what he did my warrior brah. Well, I thank you
So many people him and a lot of your fans want to hear an apology. I'm not sorry
I feel like you don't know anyway anything you really know can you acknowledge that?
ghosting him
was rude I
Don't I don't think it's not really?
You know you're messed up big time if Paris Hilton is the voice of reason
I don't know what you want me to say like I'm not gonna pawn as this person is like
Like, you know what? I mean? Like there's something like a little off here asked he lied
I didn't I felt harassed by him. That was it was still insane. It was so insane. It's so scary to me
So then she just completely changed the story because you know, Trisha can't be the bad person
The reason why she goes to him was she was scared of him. That's right
because Naqada avocado had a thumbnail where he had a knife and said I had enough and
She's just scared of him. So now that we know that she's not a good person. It's okay to make fun of her. Yeah
The next stop came from H Street Street where I followed this it was really funny
Basically Ethan did a video calling out the Instagram versus reality subreddit where you have pictures like this
I actually wanted to make a video in this my my eye. That's too high
I'm not touching that someone's gonna lash out lo and behold
Trisha Paytas saw that video cuz she was in it
I can't even tell him is any of these Trisha Peters like honestly cannot help there
Why do you why are you even a model if you're gonna modify your looks that much
It's like from beauty queen to WWF wrestler in two seconds. You cannot Foix up your heart and soul
Remember that this girl tried to use a face filter on Instagram and her phone blew up
She is the best isn't she not the best would people even recognize her if they saw her on the street
I mean, I mean to be afraid you probably do this with almost anyone probably not to the same extreme
But you can take a photo. There's no ugly photos of me
However, but over someone else you could take an ugly photo and then like a BAM photo and be like, yeah
This is Coachella verse throwing down in the McDonald's parking lot at 3 a.m
Chella vs. WorldStarHipHop. Oh
That cannot be the same person to Coachella versus open-casket funeral
So, how did Trish I responded to this video?
Of course, she had the most eloquent thought-out response that really put Ethan to place please Allah Cline h3
Do not raise your child to be as ignorant as your husband. I would divorce him ASAP
As he is causing so much damage to young women
It's basically second act. I never been more
Disgusted I think that's pretty fair. Just tweeting
Someone's pregnant wife how to race their child and to leave their husband Jesus Christ. Could you have been any more gross about it?
I wasn't gonna say anything but obviously when people attack ela it's mask off and I saw her profile pic and I go
Who was this rude person? I don't recognize her from her profile picture
Does anyone know her she then made a video at 6:00 in the morning sitting on the kitchen floor?
[Hey guys
What is up it is] Pewds: and then she even admits to not even having to watch his video [big
platform and like shaving these women like .. *sniffles*
I-I did fast-forward to my part, I don't really watch the other people he talked about Chloe and then right after me] Jesus Christ
I felt like Ethan's video. Yeah, it was making fun of people. Obviously that's a sensitive topic
I get it
but I think it's worth criticizing these things where Instagram has just become this staple of how people compare themselves to
They look on these insanely retouched photos or edited photos and be like, okay
Why do I not look like that?
When the reality is actually quite different and I think that's a lot more damaging than making fun of it
[don't need a beep beep like that down like
The reason I post those ugly photos next to eight pretty photos] wait, so she's the one that posed these photos
*laughs*
She's the one that- she's the source
Other people can't laugh at it though. [Cuz I do it, I always want girls to know that like it's okay to like
Be like this.] This was Ethan's message as well
That's literally what he said if you had watched the damn video instead of lashing out on his wife Jesus Christ
Dude, now Trisha Paytas has done some pretty funny things. She said some pretty great stuff
I feel like she does play into the dumb blonde role like she purposely try and make her stupid [dogs are and are a...
mammals....
Right? Yeah dogs are mammals. They're humans or no. They're not human. They're part of the animal
Kingdom that God created I love you Jesus.] That is an amazing sentence
[Yeah, dogs are mammals they're humans]
dogs are human no, they're not human they're part of the animal kingdom that God created
I love you, Jesus.
AAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
But my absolute favorite video of Trisha Paytas is the Teletubby breakdown video
[I love the Teletubbies, teletubbies are my *thinks*
*guffaws*
windows shut down
*mockingly* Teletubbies are my... what was it? What was the sentence? whatwasIgonnasay
Where am I? Who am I? I'm Trisha Paytas? I love the teletubbies, Teletubbies are my...
They are your what? nani? oh my god, she actually forgot
life
*laughs*
But more than my life they saved my life
I think back when I was
Like 10
Just had not 9 not 11 just 10
Just 10 not eight not seven not six not 40 not 50
not 500 just ten and I
Wanted to be a Teletubby
Nobody Trisha Paytas, I wanna be $1 are they?
Coming
And Sally I couldn't be a Teletubby but you know what this is so sad I became one oh, okay
I am once hey, I'm not stopping yet, Jesus Christ
I am a mother he caught up yet. I don't mean that metaphorically I am a literal towelettes Abby
So she says she wasn't on drugs early
Can we applaud my realness baby communists up la my realness shit but um, there's some fake-ass youtubers out there
So anyone that says real and fake is fake
Anyone says I'm so real other people are fake. They're hundred percent fake. I never if there's no exception to that rule
for those of you the less is filty and
Bitch, I'm not doing real. I like a fucking talk about everything like you didn't even knew half the shit that these youtubers talk about
Another one night you today? I genuinely do I ain't perfect. But I love the sub dummies and I can't
No, don't eat it don't
Do whatever I can't chew in over my head anymore. I look at this. Oh my god, Trish. Do you remember?
Goddamnit
Okay, that is about as much as I can stomach for cringe Tuesday's that's stricture paid us everyone
I'm sorry for bringing this to light. I feel like Trisha belongs in this category of youtubers. I just have no shame
It's like the mukbang videos. No one wants to watch those videos. You might say
Oh, well, some people like them sure like what 2% of people that's not the reason they exist there
They're flashy thumbnail and people are grossed out by them
People don't want to see that people are outraged about them this kind of content that no one wants to see it's kind of content
Where you're crying on camera deliberately, which I would never go. Just whatever it takes to get views on YouTube. There's no shame whatsoever
But Trisha is the exception of at the same time just being insanely
Insecure which is not a good combination. She does have some likeable qualities though like
She's....uh...*claps*
What you never played super simulator
You know, it's fun, right
I'm not supposed to give my opinion but give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not
Not convinced yet. Okay, I'll cut you a deal the game is available for free and that's a great price